outside building hi i'm melanie and i'm
an engineer on the soundscape team
i'm here with amos and today we're going
to show you how to develop a route in
soundscape
first we're going to scout the route
then we're going to assemble it in
soundscape and finally we'll test the
route and we'll adjust it as necessary
hi there i'm amos
i'm also on the soundscape team
i work
here in building 99 on the microsoft
campus
and we'll develop the route
to the commons which is where the
restaurants are and where we often get
lunch
we'll the route will take us down this
path
through the woods and then we'll emerge
next to the commons and find a
restaurant which will be our destination
so let's go melanie guiding amos
building 99 fountain when we scatter out
we look for cues and landmarks that will
serve as waypoints
we'll mark these waypoints in soundscape
give them a name and continue
i'll do it on my phone so that amos can
focus on the route
building 99 parking garage
okay i can hear the garage is here on
our right
approaching intersection
150th avenue goes left
150th avenue goes right okay let's
create a point here at the top of this
long stretch on a smartphone good idea
and we'll also add one at this crosswalk
marker created
crosswalk
garden walking on a path through the
woods
[Applause]
okay
let's mark this fork in the path
that sounds good
marker created
walking through an open pedestrian plaza
fountain
right standing by the door okay
let's leave our last marker here and
it'll be really helpful in this wide
open space marker created excellent
sitting in a cafe phone's in hand okay
so now let's assemble our route in
soundscape
i'll create a new route through the
woods into the commons
and i'll add all of our markers that we
just created
it's really easy to add them and to
reorder them as you need to
this marker needs to move a little
closer to the building so i'll just
nudge it a little bit
okay cool let me share the route with
you
okay i got it on my phone i'm just going
to open it with soundscape
and it looks really good i can see all
the waypoints
melanie just sent me the root but i
could have just as well created it on my
phone
the marker creation process is
completely accessible even through voice
over it's very easy to do it really
depends how you feel and how you want to
go about it
okay so let's try this
we're back at building 99 and the start
of our route
with soundscape you navigate to a
waypoint using an audio beacon
i'm going to start the route
and soundscape has placed the audio
beacon on my first waypoint
i can hear the waypoint in that
direction i'm using non-occluding bone
conduction headphones because they allow
me to hear the environment around me
you can use any type of headphones that
you prefer or you can just use the
speaker on the phone
okay so let's head off
amos walking in front with his white
cane
75 feet
[Music]
fire hydrant is nearby
beacon set on 150th 480 feet away two of
eight
garden
[Music]
150th is nearby
beacon set on crosswalk 45 feet away 3
of 8.
[Music]
crosswalk is nearby
beacon set on steps to the woods 95 feet
away four of eight
[Music]
fork in the woods is nearby
beacon set on right to commons 645 feet
away six of eight
okay microsoft commons is moving close
to the door here yes root complete
and here we are
the door
awesome thank you
routes are a really structured
navigation experience which you can
create and control
but if you want a less structured
experience you can always just place an
audio beacon on anywhere you'd like to
go
soundscape is really easy to use and
super flexible
soundscape helps me to learn a route
much faster i can build a mental map of
the space and my o m and i we enjoy
building the route together it's a lot
of fun it's very easy
the next time you go out
just put on soundscape enjoy the ambient
experience that you hear
it will all make sense very quickly
thank you and enjoy using soundscape
microsoft logo